foreign
you are watching The Press preview a
first look at what's on the front pages
as they arrive in the next half hour
we'll see what's making the headlines
with the Guardians political
correspondent Elisa Adu and the Jewish
Chronicles editor Jake Wallace Simons uh
Jake with us at now Elita will be
joining us shortly I'm told but let's
see what's on some of those front pages
for you now
well according to the telegraph there
are allegations that the BBC mishandled
the allegations against the presenter
who's been taken off air after it was
claimed that he paid a teenager for
explicit photos
that same story leads the mail on Sunday
which says several famous faces were
falsely accused of being the presenter
on social media
and it's also the top story in the
Sunday Times
woke is the word the Sunday Express uses
to describe banks that have refused to
do business with defense companies on
moral grounds
the people criticizes the government for
allegedly spending 800 000 pounds on a
new paint job for the prime minister's
plane
and without telling us exactly who they
mean or what they mean the star carries
Research into the love lives of
so-called boffins
and a reminder that by scanning the QR
code you'll see on the screen during the
program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's newspapers while you
watch us
and we are joined tonight by Elisa Adu
and Jake Wallace Simons they are both
there welcome to you both um let's start
off by taking a look at the telegrapher
and their front page the headline there
BBC Under Fire over explicit pictures
Scandal uh Jake take us into the story
thus far
well this is the story that dominating
the news uh over the last 24 hours since
it was broken by the sun
um today on Saturday
um and it's the story that a prominent
BBC presenter we don't know who
um allegedly paid 35 000 pounds to a
person who was initially 17 years old to
send explicit photos to the presenter
um and uh the money was allegedly spent
on drugs uh so the really the the
spotlight really shines upon the BBC
here uh because the BBC apparently was
told about this by the the alleged
victim's parent mother
um but failed to take the presenter of
air since May
so the presenter kept presenting despite
these serious allegations
um and this really does bring attention
to the BBC's handling of such serious
complaints and I think that on the one
hand of course everybody is innocent
until proven guilty you can understand
the BBC not wanting to jump to
conclusions uh with such lurid and uh
and concerning allegations that they
could be in the BBC's uh eyes for all
they know
um fabricated until they've investigated
them and yet at the same time it doesn't
look good for them to keep this
presenter on air for such a long time uh
given the seriousness of these
allegations and the pressure to believe
uh victims of sexual assault
um as a as a first sort of position even
before investigating the evidence
um that that we've seen arising in
recent years with good reason
so I think the BBC finds itself
um you know under a lot of pressure at
the moment we've just seen the Phillips
Schofield Scandal commanding the
headlines at the end of the day and the
week after week which wasn't the BBC
um but certainly the culture within
television is something that has been in
the headlines a lot in recent weeks and
months and this just adds fuel to the
fire uh the BBC finds itself under a lot
of pressure tonight
uh yeah Elisa we read that Dame Caroline
dynage the the chairman of the culture
media and Sport committee has said she's
concerned the corporation had taken a
very long time to investigate the
allegations uh during which time the
star had allegedly sent additional
payments to the teenager and continued
to broadcast on the BBC
yes and she is joined by many senior
conservative voices who are also
expressing concern over the BBC's
handling of these extremely serious
allegations
um as Jake frightly said there are many
questions that remain over this case not
only because we are not aware of who
this BBC presenter is despite a number
of stars coming out on social media
trying to distance themselves away from
those allegations but
um the spotlight will certainly be on
how the BBC has handled the family's
complaints and why the family felt
compelled to go and speak to the sun
in order to get their story heard
um the family essentially blamed the BBC
presenter in question for ruining their
Teenage life the teenager was instead of
being 17 when this started and is now 20
years old
um and as Jake rightly pointed out why
was the presenter allowed to continue
working on air whilst the BBC is said to
have been aware of these allegations now
the corporation insists that it takes
these allegations extremely seriously
and they insist that they do have the
processes in place to take care of this
investigation and to continue looking
into it but again it's not great timing
because of what we saw with ITV for
weeks and months we were heard so many
rumors of a feud between two presenters
and you know Phillip sculford ended up
highlighting what the real nature of
that feed was
um hopefully we will see an outcome to
BBC's investigation swiftly
to the express and this story
um reviewing or previewing the visit of
President Biden to Britain tomorrow due
to meet the king at Windsor Castle and
also a meeting with Rishi sunak and this
is ahead of the the NATO Summit he's on
his way to the NATO Summit
that's right I mean it's it's obviously
very good to see President Biden meeting
Richardson and the King he didn't come
to the coronation so this is a long
overdue visit really
um and I think that over Biden's term in
office we have seen a lack of warmth in
general towards the UK partly it seems
resulting from his um identification
with the Irish side of his family and in
fact as I understand it he's equally
English as he is Irish but he seems to
identify with the Irish bit
um given the way that that plays I
suppose in in the United States and has
certain palpable
um I suppose hostility is a bit it's too
strong but a lack of warmth perhaps to
Britain recently he blocked the
appointment of Ben Wallace our defense
secretary as the head of Nate uh in
favor of uh Ursula Von Divine the um
German Former Defense Minister who
didn't shine in her role in German
Alita do you think
you think Rue um
so we've got a bit of a delay on the
line I was just going to ask Alicia if
she felt it was true that there has been
a lack of warmth coming from the the USA
uh during Biden's Administration
um I mean you could argue that um you
could argue also that
um for the Prime Minister rishiak has
found himself battling a number of his
own domestic issues and he would
probably welcome this visit very much um
given that he's facing a number of key
electoral tests in the coming weeks um
in the name of by-elections
um but obviously on Friday the Prime
Minister spokesman simply outlined that
obviously this is a secondary meeting
Joe Biden is here to see the king as
state right he said he wasn't able to
make the coronation and the pera said to
be ready to discuss issues to do with
NATO and also Ukraine that has dispersed
sadly it's 500th day in this ongoing
crisis uh something that rissy Scenic
has been desperate to try and put his
stamp on given his predecessors
um both Johnson and Liz chess's uh you
know key links during this entire
horrible campaign and but we'll see if
you you know they look very uh amicable
for the cameras in the morning as of his
talks with King Charles in the afternoon
yeah we'll see if they're bear hugging
each other I doubt we'll see that but
you never know
um let's move on to the mail and this
story well it's a photo that we're
looking at and this is of a George
Osborne former Chancellor his wedding uh
today the headline there not even
weddings are sacred for just stop oil
clowns but it's important to say that uh
just up or haven't claimed
responsibility the pictures of someone
throwing orange confetti on the couple
Jake
that's right George Osborne's wedding
has been beset with difficulties even
before it started there was that email
poison pen emails has been reported that
was sent round to guests in prominent
journalists with the character
assassination of George Osborne which he
hardly denies and then the wedding takes
place and you can see from the pictures
on your screen at the moment
um a lady emerges from the crowd
appearing to be a guest but then pause
orange confetti over them which is the
color of just stop oil and on Twitter
just up oil a couple of hours ago
celebrated that action but didn't
actually explicitly take responsibility
for it either way it does seem on the
face of it certainly the male is
reporting as it was some kind of Eco
protest at George Osborne's wedding and
I think on the whole it seems to me as
it does to many other people who are
commenting on it this evening but this
is uh news an Eco protest it is going a
step too far this is not a public event
this is not Wimbledon a sporting event
or the snooker or anything else this is
essentially a private ceremony of an
ex-politician who's been out of
parliament for about six years and it's
really unfair to Target him in this way
despite the prominence he gives their
cause
Elita your thoughts
yes um I guess George Osborne and his
new wife Thea Rogers who used to work
for him when he was Chancellor and
managed to get some really nice pictures
despite that brief protest and it seems
as though just the poorer trying to
Acclaim responsibility they've sort of
made a number of tweets on Twitter one
of them sort of linking to some of
George Osborne's uh previous interviews
when he was Chancellor and it seems from
those tweets if it was just a boy or
they're claiming that you know he's not
being somebody that's wanted Britain to
be at the Forefront of tackling climate
change which is obviously what that
group is all about
um but yes obviously they may have tried
to use his wedding unfortunately to uh
you know draw some prominence to their
campaign given for you know quite a
fallacious email that was apparently
sent to all of the wedding guests at
Osborne's wedding guests including the
likes of you know David Cameron all
through to Stella McCartney we're unsure
if Richie Scenic was invited his spokes
spokesman on Friday was Keen sort of
distance the Prime Minister from any
sort of involvement in even knowing
about this alleged email but as you
rightly reported at the start of this
segment Jillian
um George Osborne has complained to the
police and it's said to be aware of who
was behind this email that included all
sorts of
unsubstantiated claims about his private
life yes um but it does seem that he did
have a at least last wedding
Elita Ander Jake thank you very much but
just to reiterate that her just stop all
haven't claimed a responsibility uh stay
right where you are we're going to take
a break
coming up we'll look at why some banks
refusing to do business with defense
funds stay with us
[Music]
if you are watching The Press preview
still with me Elita Adu and Jake Wallace
Simons let us have a look at the express
and this that very bold headline woke
Banks a risk to National Security how so
Jake
well this is the um an extension of the
story that broke this week that the
banks had denied Nigel farage his
account because of his political views
and political
um profile and now uh we're hearing with
some banks have uh denied defense firms
banking facilities uh because of their
their subscribing to uh sort of
ideological position that is that is a
suite of views which is I suppose Pro
transgender uh anti-brexit
um and anti
um uh any firms that would harm the
environment but also engage in Warfare
uh so it seems like the banks it's
further evidence that the banks seem to
be in the grip of this ideological
um uh agenda which has seen them Place
their business uh interests and also
their responsibilities their social
responsibilities secondary to the
implementation of their ideological
principles and this extends in a
ridiculous way to the defense industry
because we need the Army we need our
defense industry as the Ukraine war has
shown uh you know it's really I think
all of them would probably applaud our
support of Ukraine but they're not
willing apparently to give bank accounts
to the defense companies producing the
goods that we're giving to Ukraine so
this hypocrisy is never far from the
surface with this sort of agenda and
it's very worrying that the banks are
using their leverage in this way it's
reported that experts on the trend could
see vital defense companies collapse
leaving the country reliant on foreign
firms and dramatically reducing National
Security Elita
yes I mean as Jake partly pointed out
we've seen a number of stories
um from
former and currently leading politicians
claiming that they've been denied bank
accounts first we heard of Nigel farage
he said his cute bank account was closed
we later found out that was because uh
the the current company has some sort of
legislation that requires customers to
have at least three million pounds in
savings we've heard in a telegraph a
charter Jeremy Hunt talking about monzo
denying him an account uh because of
some sort of empty laundering rules that
he suggested and apparently the treasury
had launched an inquiry into that then
of course the mod has also launched
their investigation I mean obviously the
Daily Express had used the adjective
work as a chance to have a stab at these
corporations claiming that there are a
number of uh social governance policies
that are limiting a number of companies
what the investigations come up with
Elita and Jake thank you so much